♪
>> Brian: BEEN A WILD WEEK OF
ANARCHY AND DEMOCRATIC CITIES,
MOBS TAKING OVER THE STREETS,
DESTROYING PROPERTY, BEATING UP
INNOCENT BYSTANDERS, POLICE
OFFICERS POWERLESS TO STOP IT.
>> [BLEEP]!
[BLEEP]!
>> Brian: SHOCKING, RIGHT?
WE'VE GOT MORE SECURITY FOOTAGE
SHOWING A MAN WITH 11 PRIOR
ARRESTS BRUTALLY SMASHING AN
UNSUSPECTING OFFICER IN THE HEAD
WITH A BOTTLE.
SO, NATURALLY, SQUAD LEADER AOC
THINKS IT'S A GREAT TIME TO
ATTACK THE POLICE.
>> ERIC ADAMS HAS JUST INCREASED
POLICE WAGES BY 28%.
IS THAT MISPLACED?
>> I THINK SO.
WE ARE NOW AT A POINT WHERE, IF
THERE OFFICIALLY, MOST OFFICERS
ARE PAID MORE THAN A TEACHER
WITH A MASTER'S DEGREE SERVING
THE SAME KIDS INVOLVED IN THESE
SAME INCIDENTS.
WHEN WE ARE TAKING ALL OF THOSE
RESOURCES AND DEMANDING THAT
EVERY SINGLE DEPARTMENT EXCEPT
THE MILITARIZED ONE BE CUT, WE
ARE SENDING A MESSAGE ABOUT WHO
AND WHAT WE CARE ABOUT.
>> Brian: IT TURNS OUT, COPS
ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE AOC DOESN'T
WANT TO GET PAID MORE.
>> MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, RETAIL
WORKERS COME EVERYBODY SHOULD
GET A COST-OF-LIVING INCREASE TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR THE CHANGES IN
OUR ECONOMY.
>> ANY PERSON WHO THINKS A $15
MINIMUM WAGE IS THE CRAZY
SOCIALIST AGENDA IS LIVING IN A
DYSTOPIAN CAPITALIST NIGHTMARE.
GIVING THESE FOLKS A DOLLAR AN E
IT.
>> WANT TO ACT LIKE WAGES HAVE
BEEN GOING UP AND NOT TOUCHING
THEM TO INFLATION, NOT ATTACKING
THEM TO THE COST OF LIVING.
>> Brian: THEY WANT TO GIVE
COPS A RAISE, FIRST TIME SINCE
2017, TO OVER 15,000, FOR A
ROOKIE COME TO THE ONE OF THE
HARDEST JOBS IN AMERICA AND
JUDGE, THE TEACHERS MAKE 65,000,
COMING OUT OF COLLEGE, TEACHERS
AGAINST COPS, WE DON'T WANT TO
DO THAT, BUT SHE IS DOING THAT.
LIFE ON THE LINE.
>> Jeanine: YOU SAID IT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO CREATE A
PROBLEM.
I DON'T KNOW A TEACHER WHO
STRAPS ON A GUN AND SAYS "I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M COMING HOME
TONIGHT."
FIRST OF ALL, THE STARTING
SALARY FOR POLICE OFFICERS, WE
ARE TALKING NYPD, IS 42,500.
FOR TEACHERS, IT IS 68,000.
RIGHT THERE, WE'VE GOT $26,000
DIFFERENCE.
TEACHERS WORK NINE MONTHS A YEAR
AND GET EVERY HOLIDAY OFF,
ALL RIGHT?
AOC IS ACCUSING, DEFUNDING
SAFETY COME IF YOU CONSIDER
GIVING MONEY TO THE POLICE.
SHE IS OUT OF HER MIND.
I DON'T HOW MUCH ATTENTION THE
WOMAN NEEDS, BUT I MEAN, SHE IS
THE ONE THAT WORE THE "TAX THE
RICH" DRESSED TO THE GALA.
IN THE END, WHAT WE'VE GOT IS A
WOMAN AND A WHOLE GROUP OF THEM
WHO DO NOT UNDERSTAND THE
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE OF POLICE IN A
CIVILIZED SOCIETY.
>> Brian: CAT, DO YOU
UNDERSTAND HER POINT OF VIEW?
THAT SHE MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
>> Kat: I DON'T THINK SHE IS
GETTING ENOUGH CREDIT FOR JUST
HOW LITTLE SENSE SHE IS MAKING.
I REALLY DON'T.
BECAUSE I AM SOMEBODY WHO I
ALWAYS COME ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
POLICE IS IMPORTANT, IT IS
POSSIBLE FOR POLICE TO ABUSE
THEIR POWERS, THAT IS THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT IN THE CONSTITUTION,
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS UNDERSTOOD
THAT.
YOU KNOW, THE END OF MY BOOK IS
ACTUALLY "PSA, YOU ALSO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO NOT SPEAK" AND
INSTRUCTIONS FOR ACCOUNTED KNOW
MY MY ENCOUNTERS WITH POLICE
OFFICERS BECAUSE THAT IS
POSSIBLE.
I BELIEVE SHE FANCIES HERSELF TO
BE SOMEBODY WHO STANDS UP FOR
THESE THINGS.
SHE ACTUALLY LITERALLY MAKES NO
SENSE AT ALL.
THE CLIP YOU SHOWED MISSED MY
FAVORITE PART OF THIS INTERVIEW,
I'M GOING TO READ IT RIGHT NOW.
"I HAVE TO GO INTO MY DISTRICT
EVERY SINGLE DAY WATCHING PEOPLE
GET TREATED FAR WORSE FOR DOING
FAR LESS AND YOU KNOW IT IS LIKE
THIS RED CARPET THAT GETS ROLLED
OUT FOR TRUMP, YOU HEARD ONE
PERSON YOU GET TEN YEARS IN
PRISON, BUT IF YOU HURT MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE, YOU GET YOUR NAME ON
A BUILDING."
LET'S JUST TAKE THE HURTING OUT
OF IT.
THAT NAME WAS ON THAT BUILDING
BEFORE EITHER I OR AOC WERE EVEN
BORN.
SO, WHAT IS SHE TALKING ABOUT?
ALSO, HE PAID FOR IT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY -- HOW
DOES IT MAKE IT LESS SAFE TO
GIVE POLICE MORE MONEY?
THESE THINGS DON'T CONNECT AND
MAKE SENSE, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
YOUR VIEWS ARE.
A DOES NOT GO TO B.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW SHE IS
HERALDED AS THIS WAS FOR POLICE
REFORM WHEN SHE MAKES SUCH
LITTLE SENSE.
DEMOCRATS, CORI BUSH, SHE SAYS
DEFUND THE POLICE -- SHE PAYS
FOR PRIVATE SECURITY BUT SHE IS
A PROGRESSIVE EVEN THOUGH THAT
IS LITERALLY THE ANARCHO
CAPITALIST MODEL FOR POLICING.
I THINK THESE PEOPLE CONSIDER
THEMSELVES THESE MOUTHPIECES FOR
POLICE REFORM, SAFETY OF CITIES,
DEFINITELY, INJUSTICE, BUT
ALSO POLICE REFORM AS A CAUSE
BECAUSE IT MAKES IT SO
LAUGHABLE, THIS IS COMPLETELY
SENSELESS.
>> Brian: DANA, THE POLICE DID
NOT GET A RAISE.
THEY HAD NOT HAD NO CONTRACTS IN
2017, THEY GOT A 20% RAISE.
>> Dana: THANK GOODNESS.
SHE DOES NOT UNDERSTAND THE
RECRUITMENT, THE RETIREMENT --
YES, AND ALSO, SHE HAS AN
ECONOMICS DEGREE?
I MEAN, COME ON.
KAT JUST LAY THAT OUT.
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE WANTS TO
BE IN CONGRESS BECAUSE SHE DOES
NOT ACTUALLY SEEM TO WANT TO
MEET AND TALK WITH ANYBODY, SO
WE HAVE BEEN DOING CRIME STORIES
FOR A LONG TIME.
I DON'T THINK SHE HAS EVER
COMMENTED ON ONE OF THE VICTIMS
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE WOMEN, AND
RIGHT HERE IN HER DISTRICT.
THERE IS NO COMMENT ON IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE WANTS TO
ACTUALLY DO EXCEPT TO SAY THINGS
THAT DON'T MAKE SENSE AND THAT
HURT THE DEMOCRATS.
I KNOW SHE IS VERY POPULAR,
PROBABLY RAISES A LOT OF MONEY
FOR THE DEMOCRATS, BUT SHE IS A
COST NEGATIVE FOR THEM, IN THE
END.
>> Geraldo: I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE I THINK SHE IS --
HER POPULARITY IS VERY IMPORTANT
IN AN ASPIRATIONAL WAY FOR YOUNG
LATINOS, PARTICULARLY, BUT I
THINK YOUNG PEOPLE IN THAT
DISTRICT, QUEENS, BRONX
DISTRICT, I KNOW SO WELL.
SHE, I THINK, SAYS THINGS THAT
ARE VERY INFLAMMATORY AT TIMES
BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO MAKE AN
IMPACT, BUT I WANT TO GO BACK --
>> Dana: WITH THE IMPACT?
>> Geraldo: THE IMPACT I'M A
BRING ATTENTION THE FACT THAT
TEACHERS ARE UNDERPAID, FOR INS.
WHY DON'T TEACHERS GET A 28%
RAISE?
>> Jeanine: THEY ALREADY MADE
MORE.
>> Geraldo: ROOKIE NYPD
OFFICER, I AM VERY PROUD OF HER.
I LOVE COPS, I WANT COPS TO GET
THE BEST WAGE THEY CAN POSSIBLY
GET.
THEY ARE THE FRONT LINE, THE
THIN BLUE LINE BETWEEN
CIVILIZATION AND ANARCHY.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR.
LOVE WHO THEY VOTED FOR IN
CHICAGO.
BRANDON JOHNSON.
WHO IS BRANDON JOHNSON?
THE MAYOR ELECT OF CHICAGO.
HE IS AN EXTREMELY PROGRESSIVE
PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF CHINA, THE
OH, THEY VOTED HIM IN AS THE
NEXT MAYOR IN A CITY WHERE YOU
CAN SEE THE ANARCHY UNFOLDING.
GO BACK TO EXTOLLING THE VIRTUE
OF COPS, EMBRACING COPS, AND LAW
AND ORDER.
THESE PUNKS SHOULD GET PUNISHED.
YOU SHOULD -- THE REMEDY TO THIS
IS 100 COPS.
>> Jeanine: WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT.
BUT HERE IS THE THING, SHE CAN'T
EVEN STAND UP FOR WOMEN IN HER
DISTRICT.
THAT IS A FEMALE POLICE OFFICER
WHO GOT SLUG WITH SOMEONE WITH
11 PRIORS.
>> Brian: KNOW WHAT HE SAID?
GOD TOLD HIM --
>> Jeanine: WHATEVER HE SAID,
I DON'T GIVE A DARN, WHAT HE
DID, THAT'S IT, PROSECUTE.
>> Kat: AND WHEN SOMEONE ELSE
INTERFERES, THAT VIOLENCE,
SHOULD NOT BE DIFFICULT TO SAY
YOU CARE ABOUT CRIME VICTIMS.
>> Brian: A THOUSAND DOWN IN
THE L.A.P.D.
IS NOT THE TIME --
>> Dana: WHY DOESN'T SHE TALK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT KIDS CAN'T
READ AT GRADE LEVEL?
HOW ABOUT THOSE VICTIMS?
>> Jeanine: SO, IN THE END,
WHO DOES SHE CARE ABOU